a couple of features i like about the
android platform at the debugging tools
provided especially the DDMS and the
trace view Tracy was really helpful for
more technical products so you can track
down which methods are actually taking
most cpu cycles one thing I would like
to request in the Android team is being
able to inject life cycle events
directly into the activity via eclipse
for example it'd be really nice to be
able to pause resume or do any of the
other lifecycle activities directly from
eclipse Sid helpers tests or
applications to make sure they handle
all the activity events gracefully and
don't do any unexpected behavior